from an evolutionary perspective as a
feature or a bug our uh
natural
sort of tendency to form tribes
so what's a bug
oh sorry this is a computer uh
programming analogy um meaning like
it would be more beneficial
is it beneficial or detrimental
to form tribes from an evolutionary
perspective yeah yeah but but but
what is that what does it mean what does
a bug mean yes right i mean
well yeah it's like where's evolution
going it's beneficial from you know it's
beneficial in the sense that it evolved
by natural selection
to be to benefit the individuals who did
it yes but if you if by bug you mean
something that
from the point of view of the species it
would be great if you could just wipe
this out right because the species would
somehow do better yes as a result then
yes but but then you know males are a
bug
oh come on now it's uh
there there's some nice things to males
uh speaking as a male i the fact that
there are some nice things to males
doesn't mean that they're not bugs you
know maybe they're quite nice bugs but
it would be much better for the species
as a whole not to have to have males who
impose this violence on the species as a
whole yeah
as somebody who practiced controlled
violence and doing a lot of martial arts
yeah it uh i'm not sure
it does seem kind of fun to have this
kind of controlled violence also sports
also i mean the question of conflict in
general i guess that's the deeper
question
don't you think there's some value to
conflict
for the improvement of society for
progress that that this tension between
tribes
is in this like
uh experiment
a continued experiment we conduct with
each other to figure out what is a
better world to build like you need that
conflict
of good ideas and bad ideas
to go to war with each other it's like
the united states with the 50 states and
the it's the laboratory of ideas
don't you think that is again feature
versus bug
um it
this kind of conflict when it doesn't
get out of hand
is actually ultimately progressive
productive for a better world
what do you mean by conflict
i mean you can have conflict in the
sense of people have different ideas
about the solution to a problem and so
their ideas are in conflict they can sit
down with it and
on a log and chat about it and then
decide okay you're right or i'm wrong or
whatever
um
but but if by conflict you mean
a great idea to build a nuclear bomb and
set that off
then
no you know i don't see why it's a good
idea to have all this violence
yeah there's
i i wonder
i mean it's not a good idea but i wonder
if human history would evolve the way it
did without the violence
oh i'm sure you're you're right probably
uh humans would not have evolved in in
the sense that we have but i would hope
that
uh the course of
uh
violence
in evolution uh will continue in the way
it has
so
you know there's all sorts of
indications um
that the
importance of violence has been reduced
over time
and you know this is
made famous in stephen pinker's book but
others have written about it too
that the the frequency of uh death from
violence
in every country you look at
has been
declining that's just great and so you
know the amazing thing about this is
that even when you take the death due to
the first world war and the second world
war the 20th century appears to have
been
statistically meaning
rates of death per individual
the
least violent
in history
so we haven't got very far down the
course to non-violence but i don't see
why we shouldn't just carry on doing it
i think it's ridiculous frankly you know
excuse my frankness uh to to say that uh
violence is a good thing
um i think that it would be a wonderful
concept if we could evolve somehow to a
world you know 3 000 years from now
where violence is really regarded as uh
simply appalling and that you know they
look back on our time and can't believe
what we were doing
yeah
but of course violence takes a lot of
different shapes as we get
um
as we start to think deeper and deeper
about living
beings on earth for example the violence
we commit and the torture would commit
to animals and then perhaps down the
line as we talked offline about is with
robots
and that kind of thing so there there's
just so many ways to commit violence to
others and some people now talk about
violence in the space of ideas which of
course to me at least is a bit of a
silly notion relative to use that same v
word for the space of ideas versus
actual physical violence but it may be
that a long time from now we see that
even violence in the space of ideas
is is quite a manifestation of that same
kind of violence
and so it is interesting where this is
headed
and i think you're absolutely right
a world
a non-violent world does seem like a
better world i wonder if the constraints
on resources somehow make that world
more and more difficult
especially as we run out of resources
well it's going to be very very
different from what we're doing nowadays
and it's it's unimaginably different if
we could imagine it then maybe we could
work towards it at the moment nobody
knows how to work towards it well that's
kind of the stories of humans as we we
don't really know the future we're
trying to try to ad hoc kind of
develop it as we go and sometimes get
into trouble yeah that's the violence
but it you know george orwell's vision
in 1984 was of uh
of
you know two or three world powers each
so powerful that nobody could
could diminish the
could destroy the other
um
but the notion of uh an evolutionarily
stable relationship among
uh heavily armed world powers
just does not seem uh
as though
it's reasonable at all
that is to say
uh you know we've we've now got
170 or 190 nations in the world uh
dominated by a few big ones
all with arms pointing at each other
and the notion that we could just carry
on having peace talks and making sure
that these arms don't get
involved in some kind of massive
confrontation
it seems incredibly optimistic
some kind of major change has to happen
whereby
you know and some people would like to
see all the weapons go that would be
great you know i i'm a
member of that that sort of group that
tries to to see that happen
it's gonna be very difficult to see it
happen
um another kind of concept is uh the
nations themselves will dissolve and
will become
one
one government
that itself is a terrifying vision
because the capacity for abuse by a
single world power would be
so problematic and in addition how do
you get there without a war in the first
place
so you know at the moment we we have no
reasonable kind of uh future in mind but
i'm sure it's there somewhere it's just
that we haven't yet to find it and a lot
of people like in the cryptocurrency
space argue that uh you can create
decentralized societies if you take away
the power from states to define the
monetary system so they argue like if
you give if if you make the monetary
system such that it's disjoint from
anyone the control of any one individual
any one government then that might be a
way to form sort of ad-hoc decentralized
societies just they just pop up all over
the place that's a really interesting
technological
uh solution to how to remove the
overreach of power from governments yes
right absolutely and and it may well be
that uh
that
the future will emerge out of some sort
of quite surprising direction
like that
you